kleemann le chanteur qui est papa depuis
un mois d'une petite fille née
prématurément densément il est très
inquiet il a poussé un coup de gueule
sur un stade contre la presse people qui
lui aurait volé ce moment alors que son
enfant forcément est fragilisé regardez
ah ouais je suis devenu papa d'une
petite fille incroyable un petit ange
qui est née deux mois pratiquement l
avance et éclat l'hôpital ça fait un
mois que que je prie tous les jours pour
que
pour qu'elle aille mieux sauf
qu'aujourd'hui en fait j'ai appris qu'on
allait me voler ce moment
qu'on allait parler de ma vie privée
parler de la vie privée de ma fille
et ça je trouvais pas laissé faire
j'hallucine encore et toujours de
à quel point en fait certaines personnes
peuvent être sans coeur peuvent être
peuvent ne pas se mettre à la place des
autres
peuvent enlever les plus beaux bonheurs
de la vie peuvent agir sans penser à
quelques conséquences que ce soit voilà
il a dû j'hallucine encore et toujours à
quel point certaines personnes peuvent
être sans coeur peuvent ne pas se mettre
à la place des autres peuvent enlever
les plus beaux moments de la vie c'était
notre moment je voulais juste être sûre
qu'elle aille bien voilà c'est ce qu'il
a dit est ce que vous comprenez son coup
de gueule ou pas parce que certains
aient forcément aussi bah oui mais tu
étais connue non quand on est connu on a
les bons côtés on a un tableau restauré
les mauvais c'est qu'on est dans public
ou dans closer est ce que vous comprenez
le coup de gueule forcément va commencer
par le méchant qu'il ne comprend pas
parce que c'est sûr métier monsieur
claude heures alors non je ne le
comprend pas et c'est pas de la
méchanceté je vous expliquer pourquoi la
semaine dernière je vous ai dit que la
presse people ne révélaient quasiment
jamais une maladie mais par contre on
parle de grossesse et de naissance ça
c'est vrai que c'est le sait les secoue
préféré de la presse people et pas qu'en
france ça on va venir d'angleterre un
peu partout pourquoi parce que ça rend
heureux les gens voilà alors forcément
les personnes concernées slimane
aujourd'hui jennifer hier et demain
quelqu'un d'autre forcément ils ne
prennent pas comme ça mais il faut
savoir que dans la presse people c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment
extrêmement appréciée par le lecteur
donc on peut aussi penser aux lecteurs
même si slimane là je pense pas que ce
soit un coup de gueule directement
contre la presse people je pense qu'il a
été trahi par un proche par des proches
c'est comme ça que je prends le wiltord
s'est offert une des journaux
j'ai pas prendre tout le monde sur ce
sujet parce que c'est pas j'ai pas en
plus gros et puis juste si sa voix est
juste
j'ai remis la question c'est est-ce que
si nous on avait eu l'info on leur ait
donné ou pas je vous rappelle que tour
de cette table on est censé quand même
parler de quelques secours est de la vie
des people donc on l'aurait fait donc je
trouve ça un peu hypocrite
à laissez moi finir s'il vous plaît les
amis et ensuite ce que je voulais dire
c'est que c'est une des plus grosses
vedettes en france aujourd'hui il est
depuis x temps tout le temps dans les
magazines people je sais que ça doit
être ennuyant mais c'est un peu le
regard des médailles et j'ai lu pour
terminer excusez moi tous les articles
je trouve qu'ils sont particulièrement
bienveillants c'est pour ça que je mène
en bas n'ont parfois ça pourrait être
même des suppositions des choses
désagréables à je trouve que c'est bien
veillant que c'est c'est moi ça m'a plus
juste mathieu une seconde tête mais là
on a un nourrisson qui est quand même
prématuré donc entre la ville non entre
la vie la mort prématurée bien pas du
tout garder sa vidéo et prie tous les
jours pour que sa petite fille sans
people on fait quoi donc là on annonce
la super bonne nouvelle comme tu dis
c'est une bonne nouvelle on doit
l'annoncer on pense aux lecteurs et dans
trois mois dans quatre mois ce que je ne
souhaite pas imagine il arrive un
malheur qu'est ce qu'on fait on annonce
que la petite fille de slimane est
décédé ok alors votez
pas d'accord elle et les enfants c'est
le dernier rempart de l'intimité qu'on
montre dans les magazines public
quelqu'un qui sera à l'excès sa nouvelle
copine main dans la main à la rue
d'accord mais là un enfant qui est en
train de se battre pour survivre parce
que ça me font pas mature et on sait
jamais si l'asse va s'en sortir ou pas
match compliqué c'est ça le blesse quand
on est le cousin de cyril hanouna qu'est
ce qu'on a comme du privé est ce que on
vous comparer les paparazzi est ce qu'on
va essayer d'avoir des infos vous
téléphone vous avez déjà été dans la
presse people n'ont rien faire
strictement rien sais pas si vous le
voyez souvent je suis simplement que
c'est mon cousin mais vous le voyez dans
la vie parce que vous avez sur même
nombre j'imagine côté l'épreuve je veux
une table au restaurant c'est laurent
hanouna quitte à la table non non on a
plein d'autres qui s'appelle n'ont
ni connu ça va vous dit et nous n'avons
vous dire vous arrête jordana
il ya que qu avec cyril hanouna qui
arrive à comprendre le nom de famille
allez-vous de préneron jeudi laurent
hanouna comment ah ouais après je
récupère jamais tu dis jamais non jamais
à la honte non mathieu le frère
versailles du tout du tout du tout
concernant je suis mal je peux dire un
mot pays d'asie mais très court moi je
trouve je trouve que c'est un artiste
exceptionnel alors monsieur k beaucoup
d'humilité
non mais si c'est vrai que c'est une
personne qui est simple ça ouais qui a
pas envie qu'on parle de sa vie privée
c'est tout simplement
ce n'était pas le débat s'était pas non
mais bon je devais ses amis
justin qu est ce qui manque c'est
qu'aucun de vous n'est à parler de lui
mais ce que je voulais dire c'est
bizarre parce que c'est quand même un
peu le sujet la façon dont il a eu
d'enfant bah non
il avait pas et que tu vois donc moi je
pense que sur l'essieu aussi sensible
que ça il ya des christophe maugan par
exemple qui a utilisé aussi de mères
porteuses teasé jeu kim kardashian y en
a un magnifique mannequin qui s'appelle
fils à papa avec soin etc etc et qui
raconte son combat ce que c'est un
combat il ya là qu'on a envie de parler
de ça guy lacombe pas envie de ça mais
tsonga n'est pas là dessus c'est pour ça
qu'on en a pas parlé ça se respecte en
fonction de la péruse